Welcome back everybody
to FP101x.
Let's get started
by giving a little bit of the history of
functional programming.
When we look at languages like Java or
JavaScript, it's easy to forget that the
concepts of functional programming
are actually quite old and they were
invented way before most of us were
even born.
Here we see Alonzo Church.
Alonzo Church
in the 1930s, developed the lambda
calculus.
He developed the lambda calculus as
a basis
for mathematics. He wanted to
find a way
to describe the foundations of
mathematics
and it's quite remarkable that it turned
out
that his work in the 1930s became
the basis of most of our programming
languages today.
If you look at Javascript, the language
that powers the web -
and we all know that in JavaScript
functions
are very important - so one could say
that the web is powered by the lambda
calculus.
Java 8 now
has lambda expressions and C++
has
lambda expressions... there is no
programming language in use today
that doesn't support this concept that
Alonzo Church invented in the 1930s.
If we go
a little bit more towards
current times, in 1950s, John
McCarthy
developed Lisp, which was one of the
very first
programming languages ever designed, but
it was also the first
functional programming language.
John McCarthy
was influenced by the lambda calculus,
but he also
had imperative assignment
in Lisp.
In some sense you can say that Lisp
was one of the
first modern functional languages that
combines
the ideas from the pure lambda calculus
with some of the imperative features from
programming languages.
In 1960,
Peter Landin developed ISWIM.
ISWIM means "If You See What I Mean"
and that was the first pure functional
language
based on the lambda calculus, which means
there was no assignment - it was only
pure functions.
In the 1970s, John Backus
developed FP, which stands for
"Functional Programming". John Backus
happened to be one of the designers of Fortran,
which was designed around the same time
as Lisp and was a very imperative
language.
He designed this new language in
the seventies
that emphasizes higher-order functions
and specifically reasoning about
programs.
You want to be able to reason about
the correctness
of your code and FP and
focused on that.
Also in the seventies,
Robin Milner, that you see here,
developed ML.
ML also was a a hybrid language that
took ideas from pure functional
programming, but also
allows imperative assignments.
One interesting detail about ML is that
ML was originally designed as a
scripting language.
It was designed as a scripting language
to allow people to write proofs.
When you're writing mathematical
proofs, there's a lot of boilerplate,
a lot of steps that you have to do and
in order to automate that,
Milner and his coworkers developed ML
such that you could write scripts that
would do all these tedious
steps for you.
One of the
advances of ML - and keep in mind
that this was in
the seventies - was type inference.
So you could write a function and the
compiler would infer the type for you.
ML also had
polymorphic types, or as we call them
today mostly, generic types, where you
could have
a list of T and then instantiate T
with Int or String or
perhaps even another list.
These concepts of type inference
and generics are actually very old and
it
took many many decades for these ideas
to move from academia
into the mainstream.
In the seventies and eighties,
David Turner
developed a number of languages, starting
with SASL,
then KRC and ultimately culminating
in Miranda. These were all lazy
functional languages
and we will see the difference between
lazy
and strict functional languages later in
this course.
David Turner has been extremely
influential because
Haskell, the language that we're
using in this course,
is also a lazy language and it's built
on much of the work that David
Turner has done
on Miranda, SASL and KRC.
My first functional language
ever, when I started to study computer
science
in the eighties, was SASL, so I still
have a special place in my heart for SASL
and we'll definitely have a look
in one of the later sessions at SASL,
because SASL in some sense is
the mother
of Haskell.
Talking about Haskell, around
1987,
a group of programming
language researchers and functional language
researchers
started the development of
Haskell and the idea was to
build a standard language that people
could use to experiment.
Because if you want to experiment
with, say a new type system,
it's a lot of work to build the whole
infrastructure
of the language, the parser, et cetera,
for all you want to do
is to study this new type system.
Haskell has sometimes been called
Petri dish for programming language
research
and it has served that goal and there
have been written many many papers
where Haskell is used as
as the substrate to do experiments,
but also Haskell has been quite
successful as a language by itself.
Haskell will also be
the language that we will use in
this course. In 2003,
it's kind of interesting,
the Haskell 98 report was published, so
that was quite some years
after the language was finished.
The goal of Haskell 98
was to define a stable version of the
language.
Haskell being this research vehicle
has had a lot of extensions and in order to
make this language
used in the mainstream,
the idea was that we needed a stable
version of the language
that only had features that were
consistent and finished, such that
people could rely on them.
In the meantime, Haskell had kept
evolving, but in this course
we will be sticking
to the Haskell 98 subset.
If you're using GHC, as you will see in the
next lecture, GHC
has many extensions, but that
is
a topic for a future course.
We will stick to just Haskell 98.
If we look
at the status of Haskell today, there
is the Haskell platform,
which you can download and the course
website will have all the information
about that. The course website
will also have information
about other ways to run Haskell programs
and links to other languages that you
can use to do the exercises,
but the Haskell platform provides an
implementation of the Haskell language
plus the standard libraries for the major
platforms: Windows, Mac
and Linux.
This Haskell platform is used all across
the industry
to deliver real software
and also, as we will see,
you can see the influence of Haskell on
other languages.
Let's finish here
with a small Haskell program
to show the conciseness of Haskell.
This program here,
what it does
is: it sorts a list using the quicksort
algorithm.
Here's the code; we'll go through it and
after a few lectures you will be able to
write code like this yourself.
The first thing when we sort a list
is: when we have the empty list -
that's the first case here -
we want to sort the empty list and
the result is the empty list. The
empty list is already sorted.
Now the next step here says that if
we have a list
xs that starts with value x,
what we do is: we first
take all the elements a that are less
than x,
we put them in the list called ys then
we take
all the values b that are larger than x,
we put them in the list
zs
and then what we do is we recursively
sort
ys with the function f,
so all the values that are less than x
will be sorted. Then we sort all the
values that are larger than x
(that was zs) and then we concatenate
these two lists with x in the middle.
You can easily see that
the effect of this recursive
call is that we now get a sorted list.
To warn you: this program
just shows you the algorithmic structure
of quicksort - it shows you the
recursive decomposition
of the sorting. The real quicksort, in
an imperative
language, doesn't create new lists like
here
(these 2 lists), but it take a single list
and mutates the values in place,
such that it only uses the space of
that single list.
But still, if you want to
study the algorithmic structure of
quicksort,
this program is quite elegant.
Of course, we can start with this
program and then we may want to
implement that
in a more efficient way by mutating
state.
Thank you very much!
This was the end of the first lecture.
Happy hacking
with the exercises on the website
and see you next week for lecture 2.